ก็สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้อง
เรียมสวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเป้ก็มาเจอกันนะครับ
กลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับเพียร์ตีกับน้อง
เรียมน้องเรียมอยู่ด้านไหนอยู่ด้านนี้
หยุดคะนี่อีกคะนี่โอเคในช่องคอมเพลสเซอร์
โวทัยนะครับวันนี้โอเคอ้าวันนี้วันนี้เรา
มาเจอกันนะครับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกันวันวัน
อะไรกันครับ
วันนี้วันจันทร์วันนี้วันจันทร์น่ะนี่วัน
จันทร์วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันที่
3 เห้ยวันจันทร์วันที่ 3 นะครับหน้าแล้ว
เดือนเดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนมกราคมเดือนมกราคมในฮะโอเคแล้วเดือน
มกราคมปีคศอะไรครับ
ข้อสองพัน
22  5
2022 เคแล้วปีพตอะไรครับ
ข้อสอง
ต500 64 ค่ะ No ไม่ใช่ 64 ครับปีนี้ลี
ใหม่แล้ว
ไม่ให้
มีอะไรเขานักเรียน
2 คัน
565 เย้
65 ใช้เขา
โอเคเดือนนี้เดือนมกราคม
นะครับเดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมแล้วเดือนหน้า
นะครับเดือนหน้าเดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนหน้าเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
5 เดือนหน้าเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ผู้พันใช่ไหมครับโอเคนะเดือนที่แล้วเดือน
ที่แล้วนะครับเดือนที่แล้วเดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนที่แล้วเดือนธันวาคม 5 เดือนที่แล้ว
เดือน
ธันวาคมโอเคเดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมนะครับเออ
แต่ละวันนี้วันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกัน
กี่โมงครับ
ตอนนี้
10:50 น
10:50 นหน้า 10:54 เป็นตอนเช้าใช่ไหมตอน
เช้า
อ่ะเออเป็นตอนเช้า ok ครับวันนี้เรา
มาเรียนภาษาไทยง่ายๆเพื่อที่มีรูปภาพหน้า
มีรูปภาพให้เรียนภาษาไทยจากรูปภาพนะครับๆ
เดี๋ยวเราพูดเกี่ยวกับรูปภาพ
มีรูปที่ 1 ครับรูปที่ 1 นี้มีรูปนี้นะ
ครับน้องเรียมเห็นอะไรในรูปนี้บ้างครับ
เรียมเห็นผู้ชายผู้ชาย
ผู้ชายคนนี้กำลังคิดคิดคลิป
คิดอะไรครับ
คิด
ค้อนเออครับคิดถึงค้อนะนี่ขอนเดินคิดถึง
ค้อนค้อนๆอยู่ไหนเอออยู่ๆครับเขามองไม่
เห็นใช่ไหมมองไม่เห็นพอไม่เห็นๆครับไม่
เห็นไม่เห็นค้อนหน้ามองไม่เห็นค้อน
หนูเนียมขับเรียมก็เห็นโต๊ะ
her มีโต๊ะคะใช่ครับมีโต๊ะอยู่ตรงนี้
[เพลง]
บนโต๊ะ
บนโต๊ะบนโต๊ะมีอะไรบ้างครับ
มีตะปูอ้านี่ตำปู
ปูปูอ้ามีตะปูอยู่บนโต๊ะไม่ครับแล้วก็มี
อันนี้เป็น
ไม้ไม้อ่าใช่ไหมครับมีไม้มีตะปูแล้วก็โอ้
อยู่นี่เอง
ค้อนอยู่นี่ใช่ไหมครับขอให้ค่ะอยู่นี่
เอ้อพี่อาร์ตี้เห็นเห็นค้อนเรอะน้องเรียม
โรงเรียนเห็นค้อนไหม
เรียมเห็นค้อนค่ะเพียงตีเห็นนักเรียนมก็
เห็นนักเรียนก็เห็นพี่ก็คิดโป้นักเรียนก็
เห็นเออแต่แล้วผู้ชายเออ
คนนี้เบยเห็นค้อนเออทำไมครับทำไมผู้ชายคน
นี้ไม่เห็นค้อน
เพราะว่าไม้บางค้อนอยู่อ๋ออ๋อมีไม้นี่
แผ่นไม้แผ่นนี้บางบางค้อนอยู่บางด้วยนะ
เช่นอาบ้างนี้
ปากกา
เรียนเห็นปากกาใช่ไหมครับตัวเองค่ะดีเอา
เอาอันนี้ที่มาปฏิทิน
ปฏิทินมากบังบังปกา
บางไอ้คือบางบางไว้ไม่เห็นไม่เห็นใจครับ
บางหว้าก็ไม่เห็นตอนนี้ไม้ไม้อันนี้บาง
บางค้อนอยู่ผู้ชายคนนี้มองไม่เห็น
มองใหม่ไม่เห็น
มองมาเจอแผ่นไม้ไม่เห็นขอนนะครับอ้ามอง
ไม่เห็นชายครับอ่าโอเคอ่านี้ก็คือบางบาง
แปลว่าปิดไว้ปิดไว้บอกไม่เห็นใจเขาฟังเอา
มือมึงฟังได้ครับทำมือบ้างเอามือบางเขา
ปฏิทินเอาไปที่บางบางมองไม่เห็นใช่ครับ
โอเค
อะภาพต่อไปครับครับต่อไปค่ะต่อไป
นี่ครับอ่า
ถ้าหากนี้มีอะไรในภาพนี้บ้างครับโรงเรียน
ขอมีผู้ชายเช้าเพื่อนเพียบพี่เออผู้ชาย
ใช่ครับพี่ก็เป็นผู้ชายคนนี้วันนี้ก็เป็น
ผู้ชาย
แต่เตรียมไม่ใช่หมอผีอ้าเรียนเป็นผู้หญิง
โอเคทำเอ้าทำอะไรอยู่ครับ
เปิดกระป๋องเปิดหรอเปิดกระป๋องกระป๋อง
กระป๋องอะไรครับ
กระป๋องเตรียมคิดว่ากระป๋อง Coke  R ก็
ต้องของโค้กนะครับกระป๋องน้ำอัดลม
ช่าน้ำอัดลมเวลาเราเปิดเราเปิดใช้นิ้วหิว
มีใช้นิ้วชี้นิ้วชี้เปิดเปิดส
มีอะไรก็มีน้ำอัดลมออกมากินลมออกมา
จะไปครับอ่ะโลกนี้ๆแรงมาก
เค้า
เตรียมคิดว่า
มีลมใช่อ่าปานมีน้ำมีน้ำอัดลมออกมาด้วย
ออกมาจากกระป๋องออกมาเข้าหน้าหน้าเข้า
หน้าเลยหน้า
[เพลง]
ยายครับเฮียติ๊กคลิปคลิปว่าคิดว่าตอนเปิด
ตอนเปิดเขาเขย่าเขย่ากระป๋องด้วยเขย่า
เขย่า
ใช่ครับเราสองหาเวลาที่ออกพะเยาอ้าถ้า
เขย่าเขย่าเวลาเปิดน้ำอัดลมจะพุ่งออกมา
คู่กับมัน
อ่าเข้าหน้า
ถ้าหิวข้าวหน้าเลยได้ครับถ้าจะเข้าไปลง
เตรียมคิดว่าน้ำอัดลมขาวหมดแล้วฮ่าๆ
ออกมาออกมาจากกระป๋องหมดแล้วใช่ไหมครับ
อ่าน้องเรียมโรงเรียนเลยนะเคยเปิดกระป๋อง
แล้วน้ำอัดลมพรุ่งเข้าหน้าแบบนี้ไหมเคย
ไหม
เตรียมเปิดแล้วมัน
อ๋อ
ของเดี่ยวมีเสียงนิดเดียวเนอะ
เพราะว่าน้องเรียมไม่ได้เขย่าไม่ได้เอา
โรงเรียนเขย่าด้วยเขย่าไม่แล้วเห้ย
มายเที่ยวที่เขย่าไหมคะเสียบ
ไม่ค่ะอิอิ
อีกครั้งหน้าเครียดอี้เขย่าไปเอาใช่มั้ย
ก็เปิดอ๋อโอเคจะได้มีน้ำอารมณ์พุ่งกว่านะ
ครับ
หมด
ใจเขาโอเคเออเดี๋ยวนะเราต่อไปเค้าไปภาพ
ต่อไปดีกว่าอ่าวภาพต่อไปหาภาพต่อไปต่อไป
อ้ารูปนี้น้องเรียมเห็นอะไรในรูปนี้บ้าง
ครับเห็นผู้หญิง
กับผู้หญิงเรียมเป็นผู้หญิงใช่ครับคนนี้
เป็นผู้หญิงเป็นผู้หญิงมีผมผมยาวใช่ไหม
ครับผมยาวอ่ะเพื่อตี้ผมสั้นน้องเรียมโรง
เรียนเป็นเดี๋ยวผมดาวผมยาวอ้าใช่ครับผู้
หญิงมีผู้หญิงคนนี้ครับสีอะไรคะพี่อ้อผม
สีแดงผมสีแดงใช่ครับหน้าสีแดงนะครับ
เหมือนเสื้ออีกเสื้อตัวนี้ก็สีแดงสีแน่น
ผมก็สีแดงแล้ว
a แล้วผู้หญิงคนนี้กำลังกำลังคิดอะไร
อยู่ครับคิด 5 สมัย
เสื้อ
สีฟ้า
14 แดดอันนี้สีฟ้าเดี๋ยวนี้สีแดงเออ
กำลังคิดว่าจะใส่จะใส่ใส่ตัวไหนน่าตัวนี้
หรือตัวนี้ดีใช่ไหมครับจะใส่ตัวไหนดีใส่
ตัวไหนกำลังคิดผิดแล้วๆๆ
พี่น้องเรียมโรงเรียนมชอบชอบสีฟ้าสีฟ้า
หรือสีแดงมากกว่ากันครับชอบตัวไหน
ชอบสีแดงอ๋อนักเรียนชอบสีแดงเกย์ชอบสีแดง
โอเคนะครับชอบสีแดงแล้วผู้หญิงคนนี้คิด
ว่า
เฮ็ดดีก็คิดว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้ก็น่าจะชอบน่า
จะชอบสีแดงนะครับเพราะว่าเพราะว่าพี่คิด
ว่าผู้หญิงตัวนี้มีผมมีผมสีแดง
แดงๆน่าจะน่าจะชอบสีแดงด้วยนะครับเอ้อเออ
พี่เรียมคิดว่าผมแดง 5 เสื้อแดงผมแดงแดง
แกงแดงทั้งตัวเลยอ่ะอุ้ยดีไหมคิดว่าดีไว้
หนึ่ง
เป็นคิดว่าผู้หญิง
เลือกสีฟ้าอ๋ออ๋อนะคะจะเลือกสีปลาใช่ไหม
ครับอ๋อ
เป็นไปได้เป็นไปได้อ่ะอาจจะเลือกสีฟ้าอาจ
จะเลือกสีฟ้าไม่ได้เลือกสีแดงนะครับเข้า
คืออะไรอยู่คะ
ไม้แขวนเสื้ออันนี้อันนี้เรียกไม้แขวน
เสื้อได้ครับนิยะนี่ไม้แขวนเสื้อ
อันนี้
เดี๋ยวพี่วาดไหมขวัญเสื้อมันใหม่ก็ได้นะ
ถือ
ไม้แขวนเสื้อไม้แขวนเสื้อได้ครับไม้แขวน
เสื้อ
มีเสื้อเสื้อแขวนอยู่เสื้อสีฟ้าแขวนอยู่
บนดอกไม้แขวนเสื้อนะครับเสื้อสีแดงก็แขวน
อยู่บนไม้แขวนเสื้อเหมือนกันนะครับเออมี
ไม้แขวนเสื้อกี่อันครับในรูปนี่มีไม้แขวน
เสื้อตีอันฮะหนอมีไม้แขวนเสื้อ 2 อันนะ
ครับไป 1 อันสองอันนามีไม้แขวนเสื้อ
2 อันโอเคอ่านี่ก็คือผู้หญิงนี้กำลังคิด
คิดว่าจะใส่เสื้อตัวไหนนะครับโอเคเดี๋ยว
เราไปดูภาพถัดไป
ภาพถัดไปนะครับอ่าภาพตัดป้ายเป็นภาพอะไร
ครับ
หนูโห
มีอะไรอยู่ในภาพนี้บ้างหน้าเห็นอะไรครับ
หญิงผู้หญิงเธอคนนี้เป็นผู้หญิงนะครับ
แล้วก็มีผู้ชาย
ผู้ชายคนนี้เป็นเป็นเด็กใช่ไหมครับเป็น
เด็กผู้ชายให้
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงพูดพูดว่าอะไรครับผู้หญิง
ขี้อันนี้มิวชิที่นาฬิกาอ๋ออ๋อสีนาฬิกา
อาหาคิดว่าผู้หญิงพูดว่ากี่โมงแล้ว
กี่โมงแล้วผู้ชายไม่รู้ผู้ชายไม่มีนาฬิกา
ผู้ชายทำยังไงคะผู้ชายเออผู้ชายก็ตอบครับ
ตอบว่าตอบว่าเอ่อทำไมถึงมาช้านี้ผู้หญิง
ถามว่าไปไหนมากี่โมงแล้วอ่ะนะครับทำไม
เพิ่งมาทำไมพึ่งมาทำไมพึ่งมากี่โมงแล้ว
ฆ่าตายครับกลับมาช้าเออเด็กผู้ชายก็เลย
บอกว่าอ๋อพี่กลับมาช้าเพราะว่าอะไรครับ
จักรยานจักรยาน
ยางแบนหน้าจักรยานยางรั่วยินลมออกมาอามิน
ลมออกมาจักรยานยางรั่วก็เลยปั่นจักรยาน
ท้ากลับมาช้าทรายครับเออนะครับ
เค
หน้าแล้วน้องเรียนนักเรียนเคยปั่นจักรยาน
นะครับแล้วยางรั่วไหมยางรั่วไหมเคยไหม
ครับ
ค่ะก็คืออ่ะแล้วกลับมาบ้าน
เรายางรั่ว
ขอลมก็ออกไปร่วมใหม่เห่อแพ้นะครับให้กลับ
มาที่บ้านคุณแม่คุณแม่ถามไหมคุณแม่ถามไว้
ทำไมเคย
แล้วได้กี่โมงแล้วทำไมเพิ่งมาทำไมมาจ๋า
ช้าหาใช่ครับเออ
ได้ค่ะเค
เคยเคยเหมือนกันนี่ก็เคยนี่ก็
คือเคยใช่ครับจักรยานเคยม่วงแบบใช่ๆครับ
โอเคอ้าภาพต่อไป
ภาพต่อไปส่อไปครับ
เจอ
ภาพนี้เต็มที่มีอะไรอยู่ในภาพนี้บางครับ
มีผู้ชาย
ผู้ชายกำลัง
ปลาปลาแล้วปลาลูกดอกมีเปล่าไปดอกใช่ครับ
ปลา
อันนี้นี่คือลูกดอกนี้ลูกดอกลูกดอกลูกดอก
หน้าเราเรียกลูกดอกลูกดอกจะมีปลายแหลม
นะครับอายแหลมแบบนี้อันนี้เดี๋ยวพี่
อาร์ตี้ขยายให้ดู
นี้อ้าลูกดอกมีไฟล์แหลมไปครับรอปลาออกไป
ป่าวไปมันก็จะไปปิดที่เป้าตรงนี้เรียก
เป้า
เปล่าๆครับเป็นเป้าเรียกปลา
เลยปล่าวปาลูกดอกไปที่เปล่าอ่าปาเป้า
ครับปลา
ให้ครับปลาไปหาเป้าแล้วผู้ชายคนนี้ผู้ชาย
คนนี้ปลาไปที่เป้าปลาถูกเป้าไหมครับ
ไม่มีเป้ากลมๆตรงนี้อ้าเดี๋ยวเรามาดูมาดู
ฮะมีเป้ากลมๆอยู่ตรงนี้ผู้ชายคนนี้ปลามา
ไม่ถูกเป้าหรือเคยมาให้ถูกอ้าวได้ครับไม่
ถูกนะครับเออมีอันที่ปาไม่ถูกนี่ครับตรง
นี้ไม่ถูกก็ตกลงมาที่พื้นนี่ตกลงมาที่
พื้นเยอะแยะเลยเยอะแยะเลยปาไม่ถูกป่าว
เป็นครับ
เออช่องเย็นครับไม่
ถ้าไม่เข้าเป้าสัตว์ได้หรอกไม่เข้ามาในนิ
นี้เป็นเป้าไม่มีลูกดอกอยู่นี่เลยไม่มี
ไม่เข้าเป้าเลยใช่ครับอยู่ตรงนี้หมดเลย
ต้องคิดพื้นใต้ตกอยู่ที่พื้นที่พื้นหมด
เลยปาไม่ถูกนะครับโอเค
เออ
ๆต่อไปอ่าไปดูภาพต่อไปครับอันนี้เป็นปลา
เป้านะไปดูภาพต่อไปนะครับภาพนี้ภาพนี้
สนุกแน่ๆมีครับเอ้อมีเกิดอะไรขึ้นอ่ะมี
อะไรในรูปนี้บ้างครับมีอะไรบ้างครับ
เตรียมเตรียมไม่รู้ว่าเป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้
หญิงตีคิดว่าเป็นเด็กผู้ชาย
มีเด็กผู้ชายได้ครับเด็กผู้ชายให้ครับ
เป็นผู้ชายคนนี้เพิ่งตื่นนอนพึ่งตื่นนอน
ไหมบนเตียงนี่พึ่งลุกขึ้นมาจากเตียงเตียง
ลุกขึ้นมาจากปีอย่างนี้นี่หมอนนาอยู่บน
เตียง
ได้ครับไม่ลุกจากเตียงๆครับอาแล้วเป็นไง
ครับข้างหลัง
มีรถโรงเรียน
รถโรงเรียนโรงเรียนมาแล้วมาแล้วใช่ครับ
โง่รถโรงเรียนมาแล้วนี่มีนักเรียนกำลัง
ขึ้นรถโรงเรียนนะครับอ่ะแต่เด็กผู้ชายคน
นี้เพิ่งตื่นคืน
มาแล้วอ่ะเมื่อสายในเขาแล้วเรียมเพราะ
เห็นหมา
ใจออกมาทำอะไร
หมากัด
สมุดนี่สมุด
สมุดการบ้านสมุดการบ้านของเด็กผู้ชายคน
นี้ของในกระเป๋านักเรียนมากัดหมากัดขาด
กับขาดเลยใช่ครับเออไปโรงเรียนได้ไหม
ไปโรงเรียน
ยังคิดว่าไปโรงเรียน
ไม่ทันอ้าใช่ครับเพราะว่ารถมาแล้วไปโรง
เรียนไม่ทัน
สมุดเกาะขาดหน้าสมุดก็ขาดโอ้ยไม่ดีเลยไม่
ดีเลยใช่ไหมครับแต่ถ้าตื่นตื่นๆเป็นไง
ครับตื่นสายใช่ไหมตาตื่นสายใช่ครับหาปกติ
แล้วปกติแล้วต้องตื่นตอน
06:00 น
06:00 แล้วตอน
07:00 นรถโรงเรียนมา
แต่ตอนนี้ 7:00 นแล้วรถยังไม่ตื่นเพิ่ง
ตื่นรถมาแล้วเนี่ยแปลว่าตื่นสายหรือใส่
สายใช่ครับถ้าตื่นถ้าตื่น 06:00 นไปสาย
ไม่สาย
ตื่น 6 โมงไม่สายแต่ตื่น 7:00 นสาย
สายใช่ครับอ่าอันนี้ตื่นสายตื่นสายได้
ครับ
r&d เคยตื่นสายนะคะเปียติ๊กเคยเคยตื่น
สายได้ครับตื่นสายเพราะว่าอ่าการติดตั้ง
นาฬิกาปลุกนาฬิกาไม่ปลุกเปียตี้ไม่ได้
เปิดเสียง
ปิด
ปิดเสียงไม่ได้ยินไม่ได้ยินเสียงให้เขาก็
เลย
แล้วก็จะได้ยินเสียงๆๆได้ๆครับ and ไม่
ได้ยินอ่าใช่ครับไม่ได้ยินปิดเสียงปิด
เสียงไม่ได้ยินนาเกลือนี่ก็นอนนอนสบายเลย
ปายท้อง
ขึ้นมาแล้วดูนาฬิกาไอ
ต่าย
ต่ายแล้วใช่ครับตื่นสายอ่ะ
อย่าเหมือนเด็กผู้ชายคนนี้ก็ตื่นสายนะ
ครับไปโรงเรียนไม่ทันน่าทานแล้วหมาก็มา
กัดก็ดัดหน้าสมุดทุเรียนอีก o  o  o
ปวดหัวๆ
โอเคอ้าววันนี้วันนี้เอาเราได้เรียนรู้
รูปภาพนะคะคำศัพท์แล้วก็ประโยคแล้วก็รูป
ภาพลายรูปเลยมีรูปอะไรบ้างครับเดี๋ยว
เพียงติดทบทวนรูปแรกนะครับอ่ะอันนี้
หาค้อนไม่เจอใช่ไหมไม้บังอยู่บังอยู่มอง
ไม่เห็นโอเคถ้าต่อไปอันนี้เปิดเปิดเจอของ
ลมหน้า
เข้าหน้านะครับแค่ส่วนภาพนี้นะครับกำลัง
คิดว่าจะใส่ตัวไหนดีตัวนี้ตัวนี้ดีตัวนี้
ดีตัวไหนอ่ะตัวไหนครับโอเคอร์ภาพนี้ครับ
เออ
จัดไตรญาณอย่างยางแบนครับอ้ายางแบนไปไหน
มาฮ่าๆไปไหนมาแล้ว
ช้าใส่เขา
เอานี้ครับปลาปาเป้าใช่ไหมป่าเป้าๆไม่
เข้าเปล่าให้ตอบเอาๆโอเคแล้วก็อ้าภาพสุด
ท้ายนะครับตื่นสายตื่นสายอ่า
โอเคแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้านะครับกลับมาพบกับ
เพียร์ตี้กับน้องเรียมกันใหม่ได้ช่อง
ของเทศทองของเปลี่ยนสเบอร์ไทยในครับวัน
นี้พี่อาร์ตี้กับนักเรียนก็ลาไปก่อนครับ
ก่อนสวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้เลย
ครับน้องเตรียมสวัสดีครับนักเรียนบายหน้า
ตาดีกับนักเรียนม